我们最应该学习的技能是什么
好的人说我活着跟我迷茫了
我该做什么
还有人说我应该学什么专业
对
我们最应该学的不是什么所谓的功能关键
不是计算机不是AI
甚至都不是这么一听
而是
怎么赚钱
怎么赚钱是我们最应该学习的技能
这个不是掉了钱而已
不是说我要赚更多钱
谁想
学习如何赚钱是为了
真正的长痛我们自己的人生
我想一下我们人上的工作吧
就每天早上很早就被那种冲操性了
然后还要几班车然后几地切
是没有时间自由的
你好不容易要离开了
你不管这下班了你还不敢走
为什么呢因为领导还没走
说旅游啊
不过是换个地方去办工人一
没有时间自由的
然后才我自由那就不用说了工车来了以后
车大房带你要是有
还要的话你还有哪一份钱
其实你能展的钱很少很少
你看点什么东西不敢买什么世界用
说我创个夜吧不敢创业
因为你创业的话就一定会实验啊
你实验很可能会失败啊
好不容易这点钱然后你没了
这点钱可能还要
房了出现点什么
什么情况啊对吧
你看一旦出现什么机会其实你都错过了
然后呢
有的时候你我觉得是一个特别好的机会
然后之前你看人错过了
然后你有生怕错过
然后你就当了就算
然后你就套劳带高点上
就我们就像那个小白鼠一样啊
我曾比较合作是
一直本跑一直本跑
就就算就停留在原地
但是你还不敢停
因为手停
扣停
所以有时候我们也有梦想啊
说一旦我掌握了多少钱
我就去了由
一旦掌握了多少钱
我就退休一旦
整个多少钱
最贵的自由
就是等我
三个多少钱以后的自由
所以我们很多人的
大伴人生
其实都是最值钱跑的
所以我钱足老的一生
所以你一定要学会
赚钱
就你没有学会赚钱之前
你的时间是不自由的
你必须再场
你才能获得你的手一
但是一旦你学会在什么赚钱了以后你会发现
你真正赚钱的方法不是靠出卖的事情
你可能是有自材啊
对吧 可能是素自材啊
对吧 可能是
公司啊 对吧 可能是软件啊 对吧
可能是书记啊
等等这些东西
所以其实你的思维是不太一样的
你你不靠身转钱吗 你可以
实在中处是上部啊
然后喝个咖啡啊 去哪儿吹个海风啊 对吧
那么
你要学会的就是
怎么去购劲资产
你像我去拍短视频 我不会给你两所过信
因为我会想哦 这个我在购劲资产
我不会为了什么播放量啊 什么点赞啊
对吧
为什么 因为我今天所购劲的东西
未来可能会变成一种素自材
可能是转个案
可能是书记 对吧 可能是什么样的东西
对吧 所以
这是第一 第二的话 就是你有赶于书部的学里
有很多人是
活得很别去的
做自己不喜欢做的功夫
建自己特别不想见的人
但是你有必须去见
为什么没办法
生活所谓
但是一旦你不在靠
一旦你 你知道怎么这么赚钱呢 其实你可以说不
你可以不愿意 你不愿意见人为什么要见你
我可以不见的
你有用于说不得
潜离
这个时候其实你的事也是不太一样的
比如说我在给打几个例子啊 比如说你会获得思想的自由
最简单的转钱的方法
其实就是
发现别的问题 帮别人解决问题
然后你是有头闹的
你不会说被别人
会有的 你不会说我
你被人小时候远卖了一个东西然后你转身
刚出门然后小时候跟那边说 这是个傻傻
我不会在开玩笑啊
大家看那个视频的某知名品牌
当时直播 关的时候 关闻他们以为关了
当时有一个工作人员说
这也不可能没这么贵
然后另外一个人说 放心
又会买的
就是 你不会 因为你是有哪个的 对吧
而且你是了解人性的
你了解人性 你不会被情绪
不会动作控制 对吧 市场的不会动啊
对吧 包括情绪啊 所控制
然后你一点 你们看出这件事情的动机 包括谈判也好啊
做事情也好 营小的场合也好啊
就你知道他背后的逻辑是什么 你是有领性去动
而不是有感性去动的 同时你的事也也不太一样
我们大部分人的
从小的生活就是
读书然后好好读书上学上到几十年学 就是被他给别人更好的打工
对吧 然后一直在那儿本跑 一直在那儿本跑
但是你会发现一旦你能够赚到钱之后 你就会发现
其实赚钱本身不用太多
当你不在为生存发生的时候 你就可以做你自己喜欢做的事情
其实你是在参加一种游戏 对吧
然后一度遇到这样的事情 遇到这样的事情
其实就是在
在玩一种
无限游戏
所以其实
没有学会赚钱之前 你是被钱所绑定的
是由钱去动的
或者说是你是被钱
树树手脚的
但是一旦有个钱之后 你突然发现钱是你的工具
因为钱可能会变成你的外景
你可以去看得更远 你去看
各个地方
你可以开货事业 对吧 这个事件很大 我想去看看
然后这个钱的话 他可能会变成你的
安全散
你是有底气的
你不会说
因为没钱 然后你会兴趣 你会交率不会的
然后钱是你的身材
你觉得我可以去尝试这个
然后我可以去尝试那个 我可以睡眠到你的人生是
是丰富多产的
然后钱可以
购建你的影响力
所以各位 我跟大家说我们最应该学习的机能就是
赚钱的能力
会不会好好理解一下
这句话 那很多人说你自己
到底该怎么开始呢 我给你一个小建议
就是你可以不用去
什么上什么
上什么课 你就看一件事情
你花一段时间 就是写一篇赚钱的能源
至于五家的话呢 好好看一下我这段视频
其实我已经把赚钱的国家
给你讲清楚了
我们最应该学习的机能就是如何赚钱
我们学习赚钱的目的不是为了赚更多的钱
或者财富自由
我们学习赚钱的目的是为了
真正的
赚空母自己的人手